my name's rebecca smith i'm ramsgate
town promoter for ramsgate town council
and i'm also a member of a voluntary
organisation called ramsgate town team
i've been involved in the town
investment plan development over a
number of years in different ways so
um i was part of the coastal community
team working with fanuc district council
and a number of
voluntary organizations
the most important parts of
this
ramsgate future project is making sure
that we work
really well with the young people in
ramsgate
and
make sure that we can develop really
meaningful
job opportunities and career
opportunities for young people going
forward
[Music]
one of the most important things about
this plan is it does feel different it
feels like we are all able to work
together and actually everybody's voice
is important so they might feel that
they're being bogged down with one
survey after another but actually
getting that information
down on paper really helps to
develop funding applications for a start
and and and gives us a vision for the
future that involves people that perhaps
sometimes feel their voice isn't heard
and and realize that this is actually
for you not just us it's for everybody
it's for the
residents of ramsgate
[Music]
you